a lot of feedback on sour shoes one fan
thinks that we shouldn't give up trying
to get him to work for us full-time
let me play you some clips of him
because this explains why
you can't hire sour shoes he's difficult
it's just crazy
when you try to give sauer an
instruction nothing with sour
is a straight line so if you tell him
he's got to go from point a to point b
he never goes there in that order he's
got to like stop and do pull-ups on the
tree he's got to sing a song to the
mailbox he's got to mow the neighbor's
lawn
so it's like anything that you ask him
to do it takes four hours
yeah i mean i i should play this tape
during like so they're testing out
sauer's equipment
but he wasn't paying attention
you turn your camera
can you flip the camera so that it's
sideways so we're
in widespread there you go
well
when you say michael sometimes it'll
snap him back to reality you can say
sour a thousand
times and he keeps playing the keyboard
truly taught me that trick if you say
michael
he snaps back to attention people don't
understand what goes on behind the
scenes it's like panning for gold with
sour shoes you know it's like you have
to sift through
so much [ __ ] before you get to the
good stuff
yes you have to wrangle him it's like
working with cattle it's it's
you know he's a force of nature the zoom
had an echo as soon as tower shoes heard
echo
it was over like he couldn't even
concentrate anymore
and now you got to turn the volume on
the kindle down and the volume on the
phone up
[Laughter]
[Music]
dolphins
you're talking to males in the search
for spock he's gone
[Music]
i'd say this test was successful
maybe you want to stay on for this derek
sauer's on the phone and we can see
video of him in his pool
[Music]
get the whole keyboard on a pool float
loading keyboard there's a boogie board
with stuffed animals
there's gonna be a baby poop because of
this virus
so what does that mean in 2033
this is going to be a bunch of
quarantines
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
see the thing is for me my thing was
hollywood square's charo
when she when they had showered on she
did the hoochie coochie i'll show i'll
try to show you the camera
she did the little shake right that
would that would be it for me
i mean talk about ram bombs across the
room
it's so funny you you bring up charo you
have so many references and so many
stories about people
gary it's amazing he's eating now
hey sour are you eating in your pool do
you have your cereal there
i can't take
[Music]
oh my goodness all right all right thank
you sauer but it's good to see you live
from your pole there you go okay that's
enough
they fill that pool with rain water
there's not like they don't use a hose
oh nature do that that's why it's green
so he really shouldn't be in there well
there's a lot of things i
shouldn't be doing here